steam may be one of the best ways to buy  games on PC but it's far from perfect  I'm Tony and this is your overhauled  gamespot news update according to a new  report valve is looking to bring some  changes to steam first up is a popular  among friends section on the front page  the home page will also be updated with  a new column that links to sections like  new releases top sellers and a new  category that shows recent games that  have broken into the bestseller list  curation will also be updated with new  options to clearly indicate whether a  curator recommends a game does not  recommend a game or simply offering  information about a game this update is  reportedly coming quote in a few weeks  after a bit of developer feedback steams  last overhaul was the discovery update  two years ago so it's certainly time for  a fresh coat of paint keep an eye on  gamespot for any more features that may  get announced and for all the biggest  game news you're already in the right  place  you